I definitely have to start with the most
important thing I had heard that Ari was
a big fan of only murders in the
building and was only casting people
that had appeared in that show so I was
curious why do you think Joaquin was
cast Marty Short was not available
[Laughter]
it would have been definitely a
different movie I think it's good that
Joaquin got cast I mean he said he's
okay on on camera oh he's not just
shopping he's he's uh as good as it gets
one of the things about this is it it's
this has to be a very unique script to
read because it's um it's so unique I'm
butchering my question but what was it
actually like reading this for the first
time because I'm assuming you don't read
scripts like this that often you don't
read scripts like this that often Lisa I
I don't
um it is
oh not another surreal nightmare comedy
horror film
um yeah it says uh it's
um as as harrowing as nightmarish as
funny as
uh you know you kind of I I
lost balance reading it we had to reread
it again
um and was you know quick to say how how
fast can we say yes to this project I
wanted yeah
um yeah no it's uh uh yes you read it
and you think oh this I hope he's in
therapy
I hope he's on the right medication and
then you you meet you you actually meet
him and you think oh
um he's the sweetest guy in the world
he's he's so smart and funny and
compassionate and kind and collaborative
and and um and and you just think
um I I hope his mother never reads this
um yeah I don't can you imagine that
Premiere when mom shows up
um
um look it's it's uh uh you know
ariaster and Joaquin Phoenix they're the
kind of people you want to work with
they're they're true artists and true
mensches and um it was we had a blast
for soon to be fans of the movie uh is
there anything that you think might
surprise them to learn about the actual
making of the film oh God I was gonna
say I feel like uh
Ari's fans out there probably know more
about the making of This film than
Nathan and I know about the making of
This film uh
uh I know so many people take such a
deep dive into his world but
um you know every every inch every
whether it's dialogue and this movie is
so well choreographed even though there
was room to play and improvise but it's
it's it's it's it's so ingrained in in
Ari's
brain I'd watch him direct that
nightmarish scene in the beginning with
like the tons of background extras and
he was running to each one each one had
a character and a moment in timing like
nothing was random in that setup and
that's that to me I was like oh my gosh
he he's in such control of this film and
also not which is the fun part like he
leaves room for the unexpected
um but yeah
um just I think maybe what would be
surprising is that we just we laughed a
lot yeah you know and I mean I'm sure
there were other sections where they
weren't a lot of laughs but in our in
our section of the film we there was a
lot of laughs a lot of laughter and
and uh we had we really had fun I
generally don't ask this question but
I'm going to ask on for for this
particular movie how have you been
describing this film to friends and
family well I you know look I think any
any film that is that's three hours
directed by Ari Astor starring Joaquin
Phoenix you realize going in it's it's
uh it's it's not gonna be your average
film it's a it's an art house film it's
a it's a challenging movie it's really
you know it's really out there it has
you know it's a one-man surreal
nightmarish Odyssey to get home to visit
his mother so it's you know as I you
know my joke was it's the Jewish
everything everywhere all at once and
then Ari I think Ari stole it and he
turned it into his the Jewish Lord of
the Rings except he's going to his mom's
house
so whichever whichever you choose listen
like everyone I am a huge fan of Joaquin
Phoenix and I usually don't ask about
working with another actor but Joaquin
is um
uh he's so talented and he gives his all
to everything
um can you talk a little bit about
collaborating with him in the scenes
that you shared and what surprised you
about his the way he works on set hey
who one time he kept saying like uh
well we were all cracking up moments
before camera was rolling and we're
trying to get it together and he said I
don't he looked at me
all sincerity said
I I don't know what I'm doing I don't
know what I'm doing I was like I think
you know what you're doing he's like I
don't know what I'm doing I was like you
know what you're doing
and then I was like are you are you
messing with me do you think I don't
know what I'm doing like it got
perfectly very you know went down this
rabbit hole but um you know
he is so generous he is so committed but
he sees uh very
gentle or he was with me and Nathan in
his process
um if he would even call it a process I
don't know but
um I there was a day one day we were uh
shooting this scene we did take
aftertake and there was you know there
was the written dialogue and then but
joaquin's situation which is at that
point he's been told by Richard kind on
the phone and whenever you get Richard
kind on the phone you really want to
listen and he's telling him he they can
bury his mother until he gets there it
stipulated in the will and so he's got
to get out of there and get home and so
he's very upset and so Joaquin was he
was Full Throttle on that emotion and
desperately so he didn't want to really
follow the dialogue so much and so and
of course I I was trying to and then Ari
just said to me look the objective here
is you're trying to make sure he stays
there and you can't let him go so no
matter what he says talk him out of it
well that was like I loved hearing that
because then it gave you free reign to
play and uh and so yeah it was you know
it was just we just I just loved working
with autism and he's you know aside from
being a a great actor and and uh yes
totally committed at all times he's he's
just a sweetheart yeah he's he's so dear
so it was um it was a real uh pleasure
and a thrill to get to work with him I'm
basically out of time I just wanted to
ask you you both have done so much work
um did you notice with only murders in
the building that that had reached a lot
of people because uh uh I would imagine
like when you're walking around I would
imagine that like a lot of people want
to talk to you about that particular
show
um well when it first came on now
they've moved on to Meryl Streep and
Paul run they we're just older mud yeah
uh although I am the only one who would
have Emmy so there
um but
but no in the beginning yes sure you
know the guys FedEx drivers would drive
by and say you yell out the window hey
murders they called me murders hey
murders I had I was walking the dog one
morning and I had this guy passed me and
he said
are you sure it was about the show no
your mouth could have been oh okay he
seemed familiar yeah slightly
on that note I need to go I just want to
thank you for your work and especially
congrats on this uh good luck with the
rest of your speed dating